[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler pour ce face
à face donc laurent jacomelli porte
parole de marine le pen candidate fn à
la présidentielle bonsoir laurent
jacomelli merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés thomas porte monde de la direction
de génération s vous étiez aussi est on
m'apporte un porte parle de sandrine
rousseau candidate à la primaire europe
ecologie les verts pour la
présidentielle en septembre dernier
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être là on
a vu ce rapport parlementaire qui
épingle sévèrement la france traitements
inhumains comment expliquer ce constat
thomas porte est-ce qu'il ya des
dégradations des conditions des migrants
sur le territoire français avec ceux ce
gouvernement mais vous venez de donner
la parole à une représentants
d'associations qui a très bien décrit la
situation aujourd'hui on voit ce qui se
passe à calais où on a des défunts des
enfants et des hommes qui sont emmenés
dans des bus pour être déplacés ont
détruit avec des couteaux leurs tentes
alors que c'est la seule chose dont tu
disposes on a aujourd'hui des bulldozer
qui sera menée contre les camps de ces
gens là qui n'ont rien d'autre je le
répète que leur tante et la france a été
condamnée est rappelé à l'ordre
plusieurs fois par la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme pour le traitement
inhumain et on se rappelle notamment de
la loisy l'émigration qui ré allonger la
durée de rétention des mineurs dans des
centres donc on voit qu'aujourd'hui la
politique de la france elle n'est pas à
la hauteur et je crois que la une qui
avait fait à l'époque le nouvel obs avec
emmanuel macron entouré de barbelés qui
avait fait scandale elle témoigne
aujourd'hui ce qu'est la politique
migratoire de la france elle n'est pas
la hauteur de ce qu'il faudrait faire à
la fois en france et en europe alors on
la comédie quand vous entendez ces
témoignages le rapport on a entendu
sébastien nadeau on a entendu cette
représentante de l'association qu'est ce
que vous répondez alors qu'on sait que
votre parti est très en pointe
évidemment sur ce sujet je crois qu'il
faut changer radicalement de politique
migratoire aujourd'hui cette politique
elle fait que tout le monde perd les
citoyens français sont perdants parce
que les caisses d'allocations sociales
se creusent en faveur des migrants parce
que l'emploi reculé qu' il n'y a pas de
place pour tout le monde et que
l'insécurité augmente à cause notamment
d'une immigration incontrôlée de l'autre
côté on voit des pauvres gens qui
traversent le monde parfois sur des
canaux qui risquent leur vie tout
simplement parce qu'ils croient à un
eldorado qui n'est pas réel il n'y a pas
emploi
on voit bien d'ailleurs que la plupart
sont des déboutés du droit d'asile donc
il faut faire respecter la loi le droit
d'asile aujourd'hui largement détournée
par un certain nombre de migrants pour
venir profiter des largesses de la
france parce que je trouve le rapport un
peu dur quand on a les soins gratuits
quand on a un écran clandestins quand on
est hébergée quand on est parfois même
mieux traités que certains français en
matière de logement bien tout cela n'est
plus normal donc tout le monde est
perdant dans cette affaire faisons
respecter la loi contre on n'a pas le
droit d'être en france on doit être
ramené dans son pays d'origine et puis
la france doit maintenant arrêter d'être
dans une situation paradoxale où
puisqu'elle a les frontières ouvertes
tout le monde arrive mais comme la
frontière vers le royaume uni est fermée
tout le monde reste ces gens ne veulent
pas être en france il n'y a plus de
place en france une solution qu'ils
rentrent chez eux
thomas porte je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
alors demandé un servi avec sept
représentants d'associations à l'époque
on s'en souvient après le démantèlement
de la jungle c'est en 2017 gérard
collomb avait refusé la construction
centre d'accueil parce qu'il ne voulait
surtout pas d'appel d'air
aujourd'hui clairement que fait-on de
ces personnes et est ce que c'était une
bonne stratégie à l'époque justement non
la stratégie de gérard collomb elles
étaient pas bonnes et les associations
l'avait déjà condamné à juste titre
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on peut pas
laisser ces milliers de jeunes qui
arrivent dans notre pays qui arrive dans
tous les pays d'europe en réalité parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des flux
migratoires qui sont aujourd'hui
important on peut pas parler de ça sans
parler du contexte aussi climatique dans
lequel on et puisqu'on va en avoir dans
les années à venir au regard des crises
climatiques donc il faudra avoir moi je
prends un pacte de fraternité d'humanité
pour permettre à toutes ces femmes rang
mais enfin de les accueillir dignement
mais moi je crois qu'on a les moyens de
les accueillir on est quand même dans la
cinquième puissance économique mondiale
et on dit toujours ya pas de travail pas
de logement mais on a les moyens de
créer des emplois n'a les moyens de
construire de logements dont on a
aujourd'hui des mères qui refusent de
construire construisons pour accueillir
toutes ces personnes là pour remettre
chacune et chacun de vivre dignement
c'est aujourd'hui un véritable enjeu si
on veut pas laisser je termine juste une
chose on peut pas laisser des gens dans
des situations telles qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui c'est absolument inhumain la
responsabilité de la france elle n'est
pas de laisser des gens aujourd'hui
dehors
la france joue son d'abord il y a le
droit d'asile et ça je pense que
personne en tout cas ni vous ni moi ne
le remettons opposeront quelqu'un est
persécuté dans son pays pour ses
opinions politiques par exemple la
france a le droit d'asile et ça il faut
évidemment le maintenir parce que ce
sont des gens que nous devons accueillir
en revanche détourner le droit d'asile
pour venir de pays qui ne sont pas en
guerre où les gens ne sont pas
persécutés et venir en france toucher un
certain nombre de prestations sociales
là pour le coup ce n'est pas normal ce
n'est pas normal pour les français qui
se saignent aux quatre veines qui payent
des impôts et qui eux ont du mal parfois
à être aidée par la collectivité qui ont
du mal à trouver un logement alors que
des gens qui arrivent clandestinement
ses terres dans le premier acte de
violer la loi française eux sont soignés
gratuitement et logés je pense qu'il
faut retrouver un peu de raison les gens
qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans certains
camps qui ressemble à des bidonvilles et
c'est très triste pour tout le monde
pour les voisins et pour ceux qui y
vivent eh bien ces gens là ne fuit pas
un problème climatique ne fuit pas la
guerre ils sont très souvent
majoritairement puisque 95% sont
déboutés du droit d'asile à calais le
taux national et deux tiers ils viennent
pour profiter des largesses sociale de
la france une autre il faut arrêter ces
pompes aspirantes pour aider d'abord les
français aient effectivement ceux qui
ont le droit d'asile que nous
continuerons à accueillir bien sûr à
thomas parmi ces recommandations le
rapport suggère la création d'une agence
européenne de l'asile justement l'europe
parlons-en aucune politique vraiment
commune en matière d'intégration est ce
que c'est pas une grande majorité du
problème aujourd'hui de cette crispation
autour de cette crise mise en jeu contre
la gestion des migrations et de la de
l'arrivée de ces personnes là il faut
une réponse évidemment européenne et
c'est ce que la gauche depuis des années
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas prendre
ce problème là pays par pays il faut une
réponse politique aux niveaux européen
et vous en avez parlé au début de votre
édition ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui aux frontières de l'europe
est absolument scandaleux est ce qu'on
va laisser aujourd'hui 1500 2000 2500
personnes mourir dans une forêt une zone
de non droit où même les journalistes
n'ont pas l'heur d'aller où est ce qu'on
va dire au regard de ce qui se passe la
première priorité c'est d'accueillir ces
gens il faut les accueillir est-ce qu'on
accepte dans quelques semaines de se
regarder dans une glace et de dire qu'on
a laissé des gens mourir parce qu'on ne
veut pas ouvrir ses frontières pour
accueillir 3000 personnes qui ne menace
la sécurité de personnes il faut
accueillir à sais rien il faut
accueillir ces personnes là d'abord on
peut pas les laisser mourir il ya des
enjeux géopolitiques derrière qu'on
pourra reparler sans naïveté de ce qui
se passe avec le chantre la biélorussie
la pologne et la russie mais la priorité
en terme d' humanité c'est d'accueillir
ces gens justement jeu je me regarde en
même temps que je vous parle c'est ces
réactions qui nous parviennent celle de
bernard à l'instant tout dépend des
nouveaux arrivants s'ils viennent en
voulant découvrir le pays y vivre en
adoptant la plupart des codes de vie en
commun qui existent alors ça peut être
une réussite c'est évidemment souvent le
sujet qui fâche le sujet évidemment de
l'intégration vaches chevaux de bataille
sur conversion même d'assimilation quand
on vient en france on doit vivre comme
un français à rome ville que j'ai comme
un romain mais les gens qu'on voyait à
la frontière vous avez raison souffrent
du froid probablement de faim et il faut
une aide humanitaire sur place en
revanche on voit aussi des scènes où ils
s'envoient des projectiles sur les
policiers polonais où ils sont
extrêmement agressif et quand on veut
passer une frontière de manière invasive
ça augure très mal de l'avenir est donc
là encore les polonais nous protège tous
et courage au peuple polonais aux
dirigeants polonais ne cédez rien
n'ouvrez pas la frontière c'est l'échec
de l'union européenne l'échec de frontex
frontex qui a vu son directeur convoqué
par les instances européennes parce
qu'il avait osé contrôlé quelques flux
migratoires cette europe de l'union
européenne elle veut toujours plus de
migrants à l'image de l'allemagne il se
trouve que les français en veulent
toujours moins parce qu'ils l'ont bien
compris et puis très honnêtement on l'a
déjà vécu avec la route syrienne en 2015
des apprentis djihadistes sont arrivés
en france ne pas contrôler les
frontières s'est laissé rentrer tout le
monde et n'importe qui y compris
évidemment des pauvres gens mais y
compris parfois des terroristes
politique elle doit cesser une frontière
ça protège il faut à nouveau contrôlé et
choisir qui arrivent chez nous thomas
parts laurent jacot et de mettre le
point si j'ose dire le doigt sur
justement cette petite problématiques
européennes et françaises et les
opinions publiques souvent ne veulent
pas de l'immigration notamment en france
il ya un sondage évidemment 41% des
français institut csa pour ses news 41%
des personnes interrogées qui se
déclarent favorables à l'idée de stopper
totalement l'immigration dans l'hexagone
et de l'autre côté sur l'avant dans les
veines qui dit voilà ce mur nous on va
certainement pas payer pour qu'ils
rappellent un peu les valeurs humanistes
de l'europe c'est là que le bât blesse
vraiment vous dites qu'il ya quatre
français sur dix donc là reste m6 sur
dix qui soixante favorable ça ne se
prononcent pas et je crois que la
réponse ne peut pas être la construction
de murs et mur de la honte et les flux
migratoires ils se déplaceront on peut
construire des murs et se mettre des
barbelés par tous les gens quand il fit
à la fois le climat à la fois les
guerres les persécutions la misère ils
arriveront toujours à dépasser ce qu'on
construit pour pouvoir vivre parce que
ces gens-là ils demandent qu'une chose à
survivre et moi je pense qu'il ya pas
d'invasion aujourd'hui on parle de 3000
personnes à la frontière de la pologne
trois mille personnes donc aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas accepter je le redis ici
parce qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui la
france et emmanuel macron n'a pas de
parole forte sur ce sujet là il va
prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne en quelques semaines est ce
qu'aujourd'hui certaines est-ce qu'on
peut accepter qu'en 2020 de poèmes et la
campagne elle elle impose des thèmes et
on a besoin d'avoir des responsables
politiques un départ éclair est ce qu'en
2021 on ne peut accepter que des femmes
des enfants et des enfants sont
aujourd'hui livrés dans des zones où il
fait moins 5° et vous avez évoqué des
tensions mais imaginons nous un instant
la passe de ces personnes là qui ont
traversé la moitié du monde qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans la nuit sans
nourriture dans le froid est menacé
aujourd'hui entre deux états qui
instrumentalisent la misère des gens
pour des enjeux bush mettez vous à la
place d'un français qui n'a pas les
moyens aujourd'hui d'obtenir des soins
dentaires et qui voit la faute des
migrants de résine et je vais terminer
et devoirs des migrants eux
bénéficier de l'aide médicale d'état et
avoir ses soins dentaires gratuits des
français qui n'ont plus accès au
logement social probablement parce qu'il
n'a pas assez vous l'avez dit mais qui
voit des familles fraîchement arrivé
leur passer devant cette humanité votre
humanisme et va jusqu'à ces gens là
jusqu'à ces sdf français qui meurent de
froid dans la rue lance vous entend
malheureusement très peu or la france
aujourd'hui en termes de ressources en
termes d'emplois n'a plus les moyens
d'accueillir toute la misère messieurs
illustration des difficultés à faire
face à l'immigration clandestine je vous
propose de faire un petit enfin très
long d'ailleurs c'est noir des tours à
mayotte le département français qui ne
parvient pas à justement réguler
l'afflux de migrants venus des comores
et notamment des femmes enceintes sur
place on retrouve régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france bonsoir régis alors
pour limiter l'immigration
déjà comment les mahorais vivent t-il
cette situation migratoire
cette situation migratoire ici elle est
pas nouvelle on se fait plusieurs
dizaines d'années ça a commencé à peu
près dans les années 2000 ça s'est
accéléré en 2011 au moment de
l'acquisition du statut de département
de l'île de mayotte mais sur l'île de
mayotte vous savez environ un habitant
sur deux est un étranger vient des
comores où vient d'en jouant à côté donc
c'est une situation voilà qui est
pénible pourquoi parce que c'est unique
et aux très petites elle fait 370
kilomètres carrés et sur cette île
théoriquement l'insee donne le chiffre
de 250 mille habitants n'est en réalité
il faut probablement le x 2 il ya des
gens partout il ya des bidonvilles qui
ont été construits un peu partout dans
l'île et puis il ya une situation de
violence d'insécurité
permanente on a discuté nous avec des
gens qui ont vécu ici pendant 40 ans et
qui ont vu la situation se dégrader au
fur et à mesure de leur vie s'ils ne
veulent pas quitter leur île eux mais en
tout cas la situation est très compliqué
très compliqué les compliqué également
aussi au niveau de l'hôpital et de la
maternité qu'il a la plus grande
maternité de france dans cette maternité
qui se trouvent très tout près de
l'endroit où je vais parle aujourd'hui
dans cette maternité environ deux tiers
des naissances sont de nous de paron de
commandes de comoriens ou de 2 donc
cessons d illégaux qui viennent
accoucher en france donc mais en réalité
aujourd'hui le droit du sol n'est plus
automatique c'est cette situation
migratoire fait qu' il est d'abord été
limités limité à trois mois et
qu'aujourd'hui un projet de loi qui sera
examiné en janvier 2000 2022
propose d'étendre cette exemption du
droit du sol à un an pour des parents
ayant deux des enfants pitié pour des
parents qui accouchent pour des mères
qui accouchent justement dans cet
internet et merci régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france allez prenez soin de
vous parce que semble-t-il à la
situation un peu complexe autour de vous
en tout cas merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous loranger comédie est
effectivement pour limiter l'immigration
certains politiques de la métropole
propose à l'instar de mayotte de
supprimer le droit du sol c'est le cas
notamment de michel barnier à l'ancien
négociateur du break six candidats elle
est
une aubaine c'est possible vous voyez
les convertis de fraîche date voilà
michel daney qui veut mener une
politique européenne pro migration
contre les frontières se à une
révélation à quelques mois des élections
présidentielles les miracles existent
apparemment donc ça veut dire que vous
êtes tout à fait d'accord évidemment il
faut supprimer le droit du sol à mayotte
et en france il faut ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui à mayotte et il faut avoir
une pensée pour les mahorais qu'il faut
absolument aider c'est un département
français ont leurs droits on leur doit
cela parce que sinon c'est mon
assistante à département en danger mais
c'est la france dans quelques années
donc il est temps de demander leur avis
aux français sur l'immigration marine le
pen leur propose un référendum parce
qu'elle sera élue parce que il faut
qu'on veut mettre tout sur la table fin
du droit du sol fin du regroupement
familial
expulsion des étrangers délinquants
contrôle des frontières priorités
nationales à l'emploi au logement et aux
allocations sociales tout cela doit être
décidé par les français à qui on n'a
jamais demandé leur avis et qui
subissent aujourd'hui toutes les
conséquences d'une immigration subie que
sont la sécurité la perte du pouvoir
d'achat le chômage et les problèmes de
l'eau thomas porte ça vous fait bondir
quand vous entendez cette suppression du
droit du sol oui ça me fait bondir
puisqu'on vinci ont supprimé droit du
sol à mayotte on va faire des
territoires de seconde zone et je crois
que on peut pas détricoter l'histoire de
france comme ça et en vérité là aussi
vous parler de ce qui se passe à mayotte
mais il faut aussi évoquer la situation
de pauvreté parce qu'on peut pas dénouer
le contexte la crise migratoire de ce
qui se passe là-bas 86 % des gens qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
une personne sur trois qui vit dans un
logement il n'y a pas de point d'eau
donc tout ça cristallise les tensions et
on peut pas simplement instrumentalisé
est montré du doigt l'immigration et
dire qu'ils sont responsables de la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat qui sont
responsables de la sécurité alors qu'on
sait que c'est absolument pas vrai et
dans les statistiques etc ni technique
pardon dans ce pays sûr interdite donc
il faut aussi donner quelques chiffres
les
migrants sont pas responsables
aujourd'hui delà
du fait que les prisonniers sur quatre
en france aujourd'hui mais le solde
migratoire en france entre 2010 et 2019
l'institut national des études
démographiques l'a dit c'est 0,4 dans
mille habitants ça vient de sortir 400
450 mille migrants les knicks nous faut
subir en tout le monde pour aller
vérifier 270 mille personnes qui ont des
papiers en règle plus les mineurs isolés
qui sont tolérés plus les demandeurs de
droit d'asile ça ce sont les migrants
légaux ou toléré vous avez ensuite
l'immigration illégale c'est à dire que
ça fait quand vous multipliez par 5 des
chiffres
il ya vraiment quand vous voyez que dans
certaines banlieues selon l'insee relié
par le 1er mai le cabinet du premier
ministre et bien 75 % des enfants sont
nés de parents étrangers
ça pose une question ça pose une
question de changement de population ça
pose une question du fait qu'aujourd'hui
la natalité est livré à l'immigration et
que nous devons reprendre ensemble les
rênes de notre civilisation de notre
culture ne pas importer la misère ne pas
importer d'autres lois et d'autres
moeurs et de préserver notre
civilisation c'est important vous savez
la culture les traditions les rations
thomas porte à la réponse parce que
j'allais vous dire beaucoup de ces
jeunes parler des banlieues beaucoup de
ces jeunes aussi sont français
aujourd'hui oui madame et ils sont
français ils ont les papiers quand on
voit certains de ces français
exhiber le drapeau algérien par exemple
agressé des policiers comme ils hier où
il ya deux jours à lyon sale français de
merde excusez moi les propos mais contre
un policier qu'on agressait ils ne sont
pas français de coeur et même on peut
presque les considérait comme des
ennemis de l'intérieur ils détestent la
france alors vous en faites quoi de ces
personnes voulaient renvoyés chez eux
alors s'ils sont français ils sont
français mais qu'est ce que vous les
faits ainsi que son français il faut
appliquer les peines s'ils commettent
des exactions il faut arrêter avec la
logique de l'excusent et puis surtout il
faut tarir le flux migratoire parce que
aujourd'hui la france n'assimile plus il
ya des générations d'immigrés qui sont
aujourd'hui français comme vous et moi
et qui sont très bien intégrés dans la
vie parce que et il y avait du travail
parce qu'ils ont été intégrés par
l'école le service militaire assimiler
ils revendiquent leur fierté d'être
français et ils sont arrivés légalement
et remercie la france de les avoir
accueillis or aujourd'hui on a des gens
qui viennent avec leurs habitudes leurs
moeurs leurs lois qui veulent nous les
imposer et qui déteste la france eh bien
ce sont deux immigration très différente
et je crois que la dernière il faut la
contrôler la tarière est l'une des
évidemment proposition qui tombent
souvent c'est celle que nous fait aussi
nico l'exemple sort est une immigration
choisie avec une vraie intégration ce
pas ce que fait la droite par exemple il
ya des décennies la france a les mêmes
chercher la main d'oeuvre au maghreb
avec campagne de recrutement thomas
porte ça cela vous conviendrez une
immigration choisie ou là aussi c'est un
gros mot non c'est un gros mot et c'est
on voit qu'il ya une instrumentalisation
parce qu'effectivement on parle
d'immigration regarde toujours si
c'était un corps constitué intègre alors
qu'il faudrait regarder les gens dans
leur individualité on se rend compte que
c'est des gens comme nous qui vivent
très bien dans ce pays qui respectent
les lois et d'ailleurs l'insee dit
qu'aujourd'hui on a à peu près 10%
immigrés sur le territoire donc le grand
emplacement il n'est pas du tout à
l'oeuvre mais vous parlais tout à
l'heure des violences sur les policiers
mais aussi on peut parler de ce qui
s'est passé ces derniers jours où des
révélations faites état de militants
d'extrême droite qui menace de mort des
gens donc il ne faut pas
instrumentaliser la nation montré du
doigt montré du doigt des actes isolés
pour stigmatiser une partie de la
population c'est pas acceptable je pense
que tous ceux qui vous regardent
aujourd'hui et qui vivent dans certaines
banlieues même des gens issus de
l'immigration et qui ne vivent plus en
tranquillité savent que ce que vous
dites est complètement déconnecté il ya
aujourd'hui en jeu en france des jeunes
qui déteste la france parce qu'on leur a
expliqué que nous avions à passiez au
colonial honteux parce que même le
président de la république d'ailleurs à
lézat chauffé à blanc en parlant de
crime contre l'humanité à propos de la
période d'algérie et donc ces jeunes là
qu'on a vite commencé sur la peur de
l'algérie et des crimes contre
l'humanité
sur ce sujet merci en tout cas tous les
deux à l'orangé comédie est où ma part
d'avoir été avec nous